what's the memory from childhood that
helped set you on the trajectory of
becoming the man you are today
standing on the corner with Mr Mayor
principal of Saint Phillips school I was
in kindergarten
hey
looked up and there's a cloud in the sky
and I said Mr Mayor
is that cloud as big as the world
and he paused for a minute and he goes
well yes it is Matthew
now my seven-year-old mind I went
okay
I can see the outlines of it
and
that must mean it is so far away because
if that's as big as the world I remember
it took 15 hours to drive from from
Longview to Florida last year you know
and and I can't even see that far so
that cloud must be so far off
that is not worth me even considering
it's bass dreams
and I was like
Army I'm looking down I'm gonna put my
head to the ground I'm gonna look right
in front of me and deal with what's in
front of me because dealing with dreams
and what's out there and not on this
Earth that gravity holds down not worth
considering you never make it it's not
even worth imagining it's it's fairy
dust
so
I think I got
learned a lot of self-reliance
from that I think I I gotta work ethic
from that I think I got a
hey focus on what's right in front of
you
do the deed
take care of what's in front of you one
at a time and slowly Notch up your way
and hopefully there's some Ascension to
that
and
it wasn't until
quarter years later
in some ways decades later that I
started to go
oh
I can project I Can Dream why because
literally the first time I got in a
plane and in 30 seconds I was in a cloud
I'm like whoa we must be going a
trillion miles an hour because we're
already in that cloud that was as big as
the world that I saw the edge of
and then I grew and learned enough to go
well that's not true train planes don't
go that fast
oh
what Mr Mayor said wasn't really true
that cloud is not as big as the world
and it's not near as far away as I
thought
but I'm glad he lied to me
what do you think about that that
tension of a way of living life between
being a dreamer and a pragmatist yeah
which is a better way
Donnie holds the
the reciprocity the two of them I mean I
can't be present unless I got plans
I wanna I wanna have the big picture in
mind but I gotta go a day at a time I
like to write the headline or have a I
think we need to have a North star
something to look forward to
but we all know that if we're staring at
it
we're tripping on the way
if we're just you know the old
you read the Hallmark card to check irk
me you know dream it you can do it
I think that's a
half-assed horrible thing to tell
somebody yeah you know because
um and you talk and then on the other
side you have things like you know
people say hope means nothing well yes
it does that's the dream
these don't stop there it's not a period
after that word now what do we do
practically
and I think that constant tension when
that tension to dance is when it's
beautiful there's an asthma but to see
those as contradictions I think is where
we where it's fallen short so I don't
I one on their own
if we Silo the two
of you Silo the two I guess the the
pragmatics the one to go with because at
least you'll get something number if you
only Silo the dream and don't do
anything about it that's you're kind of
living an illusion and kind of living in
a virtual reality Yeah It's Tricky even
the people you love can sometimes
suffocate the dream
can uh
make you believe that it's not possible
it feels like a lot of parents kind of
want you to be safe want you to be
stable want you to have a plan so that
everything's gonna be okay yeah and the
dream feels like a threat to that
yeah
how much of that though I wonder is is
proper initiation
because if you throw in dreams out I
call it conservative very liberal late
let's learn to block and tackle let's
learn to that work ethic those things
those pragmatics first
learn the rules of the road the rules of
the game the things that we can all kind
of rely on this is how the world's
supposed to work now it doesn't always
work that way you know you teach it
teach a child to drive it's like yeah
you stay in the lane you go the speed
limit this is not helpful but that
doesn't guarantee that no one else is
running the red light but we learn that
later
um
there's an initiation I think that's
proper
with
the dream I mean you I I think parents
my parents very much that way the idea
of going to chase an acting career or
something was what
it was it was it was that was a
different vernacular that was like not
in our
I was taught to work away up a company
ladder and
nine to five do job
but the day I brought it up and said I
want to go to film School
and I thought my dad was gonna go you
want to do what boy
he was like
gave me something best advice ever and
told me not to half-ass it and
I said go
in between the lines
what he heard from me
was that made him so happy as a father I
believe and makes any parent happy
is when our child doesn't ask us
permission to go chase a dream oh yeah
when they're going I'm bringing it up to
you with full respect yeah but I'm doing
this with it without you that's when a
parent goes ah yes
I've done something right enough I made
I helped my child be secure enough in
the pragmatics to have a foundation
enough where they have the courage to go
I'm flying the nest